Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Test deux, test un, c’est bon ?
Merci. C’est bon. Ha.
(Applaudissements)
Bonjour.
Le personnage que vous venez de voir,
c’est l’exemple typique parfait
d’un personnage précipité.
Et comme vous le savez,
du moins je le pense,
on peut faire rarement deux fois
[une première] impression.
En tout cas, là, c’est raté.
Aujourd’hui, je vais partager mon
expérience personnelle, professionnelle,
sur le sujet du rythme.
Mais le rythme, en démontrant
son contraire :
la précipitation.
Je vais vous donner mon point de vue
à travers des exemples, une formule -
à travers une formule que je vais essayer
de développer au fil de cette conférence.
Rythme ne veut pas dire précipitation.
Le rythme individuel,
le rythme des choses,
le rythme collectif,
n’est pas à confondre avec
la précipitation, son ennemi numéro un.
Et des fois je me demande :
on vit dans un monde de fous quand même !
Il y a deux mois, en bas de chez moi,
deux automobilistes sortent
de leur voiture, se tapent dessus,
parce qu’un camion bloque le passage.
Mais ce manque de temps,
cette impatience, cette précipitation,
elle vient d’un manque
de temps, quelque part.
Donc si on est pressé, précipité,
c’est que le facteur temps y est réduit.
Mais comme on faisait avant les horloges,
avant les iPhones, avant les montres,
pour calculer le temps
et pour être, par exemple, à l’heure
au restaurant avec sa copine ?
Je ne me suis pas présenté,
je m’appelle Mehdi Hocine.
Je suis technicien de formation.
Je suis commercial, comédien, réalisateur,
je réalise des vidéos pour les comédiens,
j’écris, je réalise et je produis.
Et ensemble, nous allons faire
un petit tour dans l’histoire
pour comprendre comment
on faisait pour mesurer le temps
et comment nous sommes arrivés jusqu’ici.
Ici, vous avez la clepsydre.
Elle était bien connue
des Amérindiens et des Égyptiens.
C’est comme un sablier,
vous avez deux pots.
Le deuxième petit pot
a des graduations à l’intérieur.
Vous avez l’eau qui coule
et vous avez le calcul de la mesure
grâce aux graduations.
Vous avez son grand frère, le sablier.
Le sablier c’est la même chose
mais avec un temps précis, avec du sable.
Et tout le monde, je pense,
connaît les cadrans solaires.
Grâce à la lumière du soleil,
l’ombre de la tige
nous permettait justement de savoir
où nous étions dans la journée.
Et là, nous avons une des premières
horloges mécaniques sonnantes,
au 14ᵉ siècle.
C’est super important,
parce que ces horloges, elles n’avaient
ni aiguilles, ni cadran.
Elles étaient accrochées au clocher
des églises ou au clocher des villes.
Et leur seule fonction,
c’était de sonner toutes les heures.
Et à partir de ce moment-là,
on savait quand il fallait travailler,
quand était le couvre-feu,
quand prendre sa pause,
quand aller au restaurant avec sa copine,
Les gens n’étaient plus payés,
à la tâche réalisée,
mais ils étaient payés à l’heure.
«The time is money»
de Benjamin Franklin,
on connaît tous cette phrase.
Donc, on voit que nous avons été entraînés
par l’Histoire sur cette mesure
et on peut dire qu’à partir
de cette époque,
nous avons été soumis au temps mécanique.
Maintenant, revenons à la précipitation.
J'ai trouvé une petite formule.
Ça m'arrive des fois, je trouve
des petites formules.
Le temps plus de l’énergie
égale du résultat.
Donc le temps passé au travail,
mes 8 heures de travail,
plus l’énergie dépensée
au travail, égale du résultat.
Mais si j’ai moins de temps, par exemple,
pour produire un résultat.
Si j’ai 5 heures au lieu de 8 heures,
ça nécessite plus d’énergie.
Et si j’ai moins d’énergie,
par exemple si je suis malade,
ça nécessite plus de temps.
Pendant la pandémie, j’avais
un rendez-vous hyper important.
Je me suis réveillé hyper en retard.
Je me suis réveillé, j’ai mis mon
pantalon froissé, j’ai bu mon café froid,
j'ai mis dix minutes à mettre ma montre.
Je déboule l’escalier,
ouf, j’ai mon portefeuille.
Je rentre dans le métro,
ouf, j’ai mon pass Navigo.
Je rentre dans le métro, et là...
j’ai oublié mon masque.
Donc vous voyez que le surplus d’énergie
et moins de temps, n’égale pas
forcément le même résultat.
Donc on peut dire que la précipitation,
c’est estimer avoir le même résultat
en donnant plus d’énergie,
en ayant moins le temps.
Voyons maintenant pour le rythme.
Je vais parler de ce que
je connais : le théâtre.
On dit que le théâtre, la base,
c'est le rythme et l'énergie.
Sans rythme, il n’y a pas d’énergie,
il n’y a pas théâtre.
Feydeau, un auteur bien connu,
faisait jouer ses comédiens
sur le rythme d’un piano.
Dans Les Fourberies
de Scapin, scène V, acte II,
Scapin essaie de soutirer de l’argent
à un de ses maîtres.
Je vais vous la jouer de façon précipitée
et je vais vous la jouer de façon rythmée.
Donc de la façon précipitée, ça fait :
«Monsieur, votre serviteur,
*- Bonjour Scapin, ... [scande rapidement]
... peut rencontrer
l’argent volé, sa fille dérobée,
ou son argent dérobé.»
Et de façon bien rythmée :
Je vais la jouer - même moi,
je n’ai rien compris, donc, vous voyez...
Je me suis même trompé
sur le texte pour vous avouer.
De façon bien rythmée, ça fait :
«Monsieur, votre serviteur.
- Bonjour Scapin,
que pour peu qu’un père de famille
ait été absent de chez lui,
il doit promener son esprit sur tous les
accidents que son retour peut rencontrer.
Se figurer sa maison brûlée,
son argent dérobé, sa femme morte,
son fils estropié, sa fille subornée ;
et ce qu’il trouve
qui ne lui est point arrivé,
l’imputer à bonne fortune.»
Il y a des ralentissements,
il y a des temps, il y a de la nuance,
il y a du rythme.
Et quand il y a des temps,
il y a du rythme,
il y a le silence.
Et on dit souvent que
le silence, le temps,
l’écoute est un art.
Et dans le silence,
il y a le temps et l’écoute.
Quand j’étais commercial -
je tapais aux portes à 18 ans
pour vendre des produits -
j’ai remarqué quelque chose.
J’avais deux choix, des fois,
qui s’offraient à moi.
Soit je gardais ma précipitation,
soit je me mettais sur la même cadence
que mon interlocuteur.
Et je commençais à parler d’un air -
beaucoup plus lent,
avec une meilleure cadence.
Donc, j’étais sur ses vibrations,
j’étais sur son rythme.
On dit aussi que l’écoute est un art,
au cinéma, au théâtre, c’est pareil.
Par exemple, pour un comédien, j’ai écrit
une scène dramatique -
je vous fait le pitch en une minute :
il arrive, complètement bourré.
Sa femme l’attend, chez lui directement.
Une querelle s'annonce.
Ils s’engueulent.
Et là,
il dit une phrase, il dit :
«De toute façon, dégage,
tu peux aller crever.»
Silence.
Elle a écouté.
Elle s'écoute.
Elle se dit peut-être :
«Tout ce chemin pour en arriver là.»
Vous voyez que la patience
de l’écoute donne du rythme.
Le temps et le silence donnent du rythme.
Nelson Mandela,
paix à son âme, un grand homme -
Le père de Nelson Mandela, lui,
c’était le meilleur des conseillers
du roi de son village, le roi Thembu.
C’était le meilleur.
Et vous savez pourquoi
c’était le meilleur ?
Parce qu’après avoir écouté
tous les autres conseillers,
il prenait l’avis de tous les autres,
pour en donner le sien.
Donc la patience de l’écoute,
c’est quelque chose d’essentiel.
Un état d'esprit.
Alors, un état d’esprit,
en étant comédien,
j’ai compris quelque chose,
c’est que je peux être différent
tout en restant moi-même.
Mon professeur me disait :
«Écoute, Mehdi, tu sais,
tu prends un verre d’eau.
Donc le verre d’eau
qui est à l’image du comédien,
et le sucre est le rôle
qu’il doit jouer.»
Le sucre, on le met dans l’eau,
on tourne,
on boit.
L’eau devient sucrée,
mais reste transparente.
La persona,
c’est le masque que mettait les Grecs
pour identifier les caractères de jeu.
Le valet de comédie, le jeune premier,
la jeune première, le cocu, le naïf, etc.
Mais ils l’enlevaient à la fin.
Et nous de notre côté, la personna-lité,
nous pouvons bien l’enlever.
Quand on sort du travail pour embrasser
ses enfants à la maison,
nous pouvons l’enlever.
Un colonel haut gradé
peut tout à fait jouer à la Barbie
de façon impliquée, avec sa petite fille.
À chaque situation, son propre rythme.
Et je dirais
qu’une petite impatience
peut ruiner un grand projet.
Et n’oubliez jamais que c’est toujours
l’envie de gagner
qui fait perdre.
Je vais finir par une citation :
« La nature ne se hâte point,
pourtant, tout est accompli. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)